[Music]
thanks to Eckerman snows we know that
the birth of world literature took place
in the afternoon of January 31st 1827 at
grutas house by that time a gunman had
been in vain for over a year and a half
and had settled into a routine a few
times a week he would have dinner at
Goethe's on that Wednesday he hadn't
been spin at Goethe's for several days
so good had all kinds of thoughts and
reflections penned up and was holding
forth reporting on what he had done and
read since they last met apparently he
had been reading a Chinese novel really
that must have been rather strange a
time unexplained but this was not the
right reaction after a year and a half I
Carmen had still not fully understood
his master no much less so than one
thing through the reprimanded him and
began to lecture Ackerman liked it when
Goethe lecture it was always something
to be learned but it started about the
influence of the British writer same old
Richardson on his own work which
Ackerman listened to with polite
interest but before long really came
back to Chinese novels and man Ackerman
was still skeptical what these Chinese
novels are useless more decent than the
French greater applied which wasn't
saying much
Ackerman ventured that this Chinese
novel must be quite unusual the
exception to the real
wrong again the master's voice was Stern
nothing could be further from the truth
the Chinese have thousands of them and
they had them when our ancestors were
still living in the trees Ackerman was
speechless greater took advantage of the
silence and topped the last claim with
the truly ludicrous one the time has
come for the epoch of world literature
and everyone must seek to accelerate it
everyone and that includes you you my
young and ignorant friend who you me
everyone and especially Ackerman must
accelerate the process of world
literature must read Chinese novel
thousands of them Ackerman was shocked
realizing that Yugi had opened a can of
worms but fortunately he got distracted
there was a noise outside the window
excited he jumped up and went to the
window to look outside included at the
same they were expecting the return of
horse drones drawn sledges that had left
in the morning one of the more exciting
things that could happen on a by Mars
late afternoon suddenly Ackerman and
Goethe didn't care at all about Chinese
novels and world literature they pressed
their nose against the window to get a
better look at the street but it wasn't
the sledges and so they got back to
their seats disappointed where were we
is rose literature good is started
talking again until there was another
noise outside in Egremont and Gerda once
again dropped the conversation to look
out the window but it still wasn't those
legends and suddenly went back to their
seats and greeted talk to visit max
rather listless leads until it was time
for Ackerman to leave this was the birth
of world literature
[Music]